Australia's foreign minister says China
is subjecting one of its citizens to
daily interrogations including whilst
being shackled pro-democracy rioter Yong
Cheng Jun has been detained in China
since January has been accused of spying
Maurice pain the Australian Foreign
Minister says Yang is being held in
unacceptable conditions and is urging
Beijing to release him more on this with
Patrick poon joining us from Hong Kong
Amnesty International's China researcher
thanks for your time Patrick I don't
think this is a case or a story that
many people will necessarily have heard
about until it's a little bit more about
what yang was doing that led to charges
of espionage this very concerning SC for
most mentioned Vegas for spying this
panache that actually can mean like very
serious punishment if convicted
like even up to life imprisonment for
example so I think like the problem is
like how he is treated is quite typical
of dissidents in China and they have no
access to lawyers and their family and
it makes it like a very make them very
vulnerable to high resource torture
another new treatment and then now also
yes what any like heard from this case
new treatment has already happened so I
think it is something what concerns us
most is how we can push China more to
allow him at least to have meeting with
his lawyers and so that leads to the
question how can you do that and given
be dealing anyone
excuse me dealing with the government of
China as a would be quite fraught I
would think I think like the only way
that would be to have more international
pressure now I see Australia's been
raising concern about a case but if we
have more voices from other countries
and also at the United Nations you can
help the case to have a high profile and
China has no choice but to respond to it
cause like on surface they were always
like responds by saying they had been
using very tactful lawful and very legal
means to deal with the case and but
actually like we see how international
pressure can help to put more pressure
on China to improve the situation of
detainees so I think that was something
that we need to do to push more on
Chinese government Patrick what was mr.
yang doing what was he was he was he in
his writing was he directly criticizing
the Chinese government like what I see
like his writings in the past few years
maybe like like from a very academic
writers point of view giving comments on
the Chinese government's policies and
human rights violations so strictly
speaking we don't see anything like
problematic before Chinese government of
course they see any criticism can be
considered some wording which the
government and now even like was saying
like accusing him of espionage but for
espionage cases they always just hold
the trial secret Chow and there's no way
to find out what would be the actual
evidence couldn't against him
so I think the worrying part is how the
so-called trial will happen or it will
happen at all
how it would be contacted and whether
his family members would be allowed to
see in the trial how the child would be
[Music]
manner so something like is a big
concern on how he would be tried but
unfortunately from periods experienced
in other cases if it's very likely that
he won't be giving that fair trial
Patrick came from Amnesty International
thank you for your time - appreciate it